welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and a Disney investor call that
happened this afternoon confirmed Disney
and Marvel Studios slate for 2024 2025
and starting to get a sneak peek at 2026
we learned that Disney is partnering
with fortnite in a $1.5 billion deal
that's basically going to create the
Oasis from Ready Player one I'm going to
break down everything that we learned
from this Disney investor call and
before we begin new rockstars is doing a
live show on Thursday February 15th in
Los Angeles we're going to talk about
the trailers from the Super Bowl we're
going to talk about all this stuff we
just learned do some stuff in person
with all guys that we never get to do on
YouTube so please come hang out with us
tickets are still available in the
description below okay here's what we
learned Disney slate coming forward the
rest of this year is going to include as
planned pixars Inside Out 2 that's
coming June 2024 of course Marvel
Studios Deadpool 3 coming July 2024 Bob
Iger confirm that Agatha darkle Diaries
is probably going to be renamed like
Agatha all along in my opinion he said
some good stuff about it and it's
probably going to come sometime in the
fourth quarter during the Halloween time
of this year and of course we're still
getting The Lion King prequel movie
muasa coming to December and when they
announc this at d23 that I was at in
2022 I accidentally tweeted this was
called Joe muasa and that's just what
I'm going to call this movie Joe Mufasa
okay but big announcement for this year
Moana 2 is coming November 27th 2024
interesting release date because I
believe currently that is the same
weekend for Wicked maybe Universal will
move it we'll see I'm super excited for
Moana 2 it doesn't look like ly Mel
Miranda is coming back to do the music
though so we'll see now for Disney's
slate in 2025 they confirmed that
Captain America Brave New World the
fourth Captain America movie is still
coming current release date is
Valentine's Day 2025 as well as
Fantastic 4 coming May 2025 but as of
now they have not confirmed the cast
although there was like some news from
sag earlier today that Pedra Pascal is
beginning to shoot Fantastic 4 in the
coming weeks he's probably going to be
our Reed Richards Mr Fantastic but it
has not been confirmed yet Pixar's Elio
there was a trailer for Pixar's Elio but
it has now been removed to 2025 as they
rework parts of that movie zootopia 2o
is coming in 2025 and Avatar 3 which I
believe is going to be called Avatar the
seed Bearer that is slated for December
2025 but what is interesting about this
announcement is we haven't heard
anything about Thunderbolts we haven't
heard anything about blade in this
announcement Thunderbolts has had some
casting shakeup Steven Yun has been
replaced by it looks like leis pman for
the character of sentury AO edir is now
not going to be part of the cast and we
know blade has gone through several
different plot reworkings and just no
information on that yet doesn't mean
these two movies have been moved out of
2025 we will see now 2026 from the disne
Disney Empire we are getting Frozen 3
and Toy Story 5 2026 is also the target
date for the Mandalorian and grou this
is the Mando grou movie that was
announced a couple weeks ago this will
be coming in 2026 and I'm sure we're
going to have some Marvel movies coming
in 2026 they just didn't lock anything
down yet but also a pretty big
announcement for I know some of you
Taylor Swift eras is coming to Disney
Plus on March 15th 2024 just a few weeks
from now and with this stream are going
to be five new songs so if you like like
me and you saw Taylor Swift erid in the
theaters you know that they didn't
include all of the songs that you would
see in a concert because every time
Taylor went to a new location she would
kind of rotate out different songs so
they're going to be five new songs we
don't know which ones they're going to
be the reason I'm interested in this is
if you watch my video from last week I
think it's just interesting that Taylor
Swift has this partnership with Disney
who knows how big of a deal that was I
assume it was much bigger than what Lyn
Manuel Miranda got for releasing
Hamilton on Disney plus but this is
going to be huge for the platform
obviously and hey we'll see we'll see if
we uh learn some other stuff about
Taylor Swift partnering with like Marvel
Studios in Deadpool 3 please go watch my
crazy conspiracy video about the NFL and
Taylor Swift and Ryan Reynolds and
Deadpool 3 because while you know I
think there are some conspiracy theories
involved with that it's definitely clear
that the NFL and the networks jumped on
the bandwagon of the Taylor Swift Travis
Kelce marketing at the very least and I
think that story alone is very
interesting okay let's react to this new
epic games fortnite promo showing
Disney's partnership with
them discover a play
what okay we're
magic these Mad Men are doing
it my
God what
what whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
and that has to be what like Disneyland
becomes I think right so I'm just going
to look at what I can see in this map
right here let's see I see Stark Tower
but it's like a different Stark Tower
this is not avengers Tower this is a
different building maybe it part of like
an Avengers campus but hopefully better
than what Avengers campus is when you go
to Disneyland because I'm not a huge fan
of it some glimpses of The Nightmare
Before Christmas it looks like part of
Radiator Springs because that's a V8
Cafe From Radiator Springs when you go
to Disneyland Monsters University campus
looks like the building from Wreck and
Ralph there's definitely
what looks like the black Spire Outpost
of Batu from Galaxy's Edge stop for the
Disney Cruise Line and then this other
kind of corpor section where there's
like a building for ESPN just a general
section for Disney plus we see the Pixar
Luxo ball we see a 20th Century Fox area
they just call 20th century now a
building for lucasfilm a building for
Marvel and then over in this corner
there is like the Star Wars battle of
Hoth with the Death Star looming over it
and another corner you see Pandora from
the Avatar Universe with the the
floating islands there definitely what
looks like Neverland from you know the
Peter Pan section of the universe all
over the place they're like floating
x-wings and other ships from Star Wars
it looks like that might be Arendelle
from Frozen the fact that we're getting
a Frozen 3 obviously Disney feels
bullish on that that looks like the
floating skull of nowhere and hey if you
were to reimagine like a Disney
Experience can we get the location of
the nowhere skull as something that is
visitable because I went to go to there
and it's just awesome and there's so
much that can be done and explored there
today's video is sponsored by blueo and
look I'm neither Suave enough nor gross
enough to talk about sex comfortably but
you know things change as you age and if
you want to turn back the clock to a
more energetic time in your life
blue.com can help blueo is the unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra Calis and
Levitra but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you can take them
anytime day or night that way you can
plan ahead or be ready for whenever an
opportunity arises it's super easy to do
just sign up at blu.com consult with one
of their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you will receive
your prescription within days it's all
done online that means no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line of the pharmacy
Blue Cho tablets are made in the USA and
prepared and Shi direct to your door in
a discret package if you're skeptical or
you don't think you'll need it try it
free for a month and see blue Chu wants
to help you have better sex discover
your options at blue.com chew it and do
it we've got a special deal for our
audience try blueo free when you use our
promo code new rockstars at checkout
just pay $5 in shipping that's blu.com
promo code new rockstars to receive your
first mon on free just $5 in shipping
visit blue.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank blueo for sponsoring our Channel
okay other news that we learned ESPN is
launching as its own streaming service
that is coming fall 2025 maybe as early
as August 2025 I have to imagine they're
going to want to have it ready by August
for the start of the football season
college football and NFL games so expect
to see that rolling out in August 2025
we also learned that Percy Jackson is
got renewed for a season 2 on Disney
plus they said that season 1 generated
more than 110 million hour stream to
date I don't know what that means but
the premiere episode amassed like 26.2
million views in its first 3 weeks on
Disney plus and Hulu which also carried
it so yeah this is different than what
we normally hear from Disney plus it's
just they'll just do one season of
something and then never renew it Loki
obviously with the exception of that as
well as what if but Percy Jackson has
been a a huge success for the platform I
have not gotten around to watching it
but I think I'm going to have to go
watch it now okay so what are the big
takeaways here obviously Bob Iger admits
that you know 2023 wasn't the best year
for Disney but looking ahead Deadpool 3
is probably going to be the highest
grossy movie of the year maybe one of
the three candidates that I think has a
good shot of making a billion dollars
the other two being Despicable Me for
and wicked I just feel weirdly confident
that wicked's going to do very well but
maybe now that Moana 2 is releasing on
the same day I could also just see like
Universal deciding to move Wicked to a
different release day in a few days
we're going to get the Super Bowl and
we're confirmed to see trailers for
Deadpool 3 probably Universal's Twisters
sequel yeah we're getting twisted and a
few other movies so here on new
rockstars we are going to be doing a
live stream as the Super Bowl game comes
to an end the new rockstars crew is
going to be reacting to all the big news
that we learned during the commercial
breaks and probably the game itself but
before that stream here on the new
Rockstar Channel you're going to see my
reaction to the Deadpool 3 trailer
Jessica Clemens is going to be reacting
to whatever other big trailers happen on
that day and then the week following
that we're going to be breaking down
everything with more detail and going
through it frame by frame the classic
Easter egg breakdowns that you come to
expect from us I don't know I will say I
was hoping for a like a Fantastic 4
announcement but I think we're going to
get that in the coming days Mandalorian
and grou I was hoping they could finish
and then release sometime in 2025 but
the good news is finally we're getting
Star Wars movies again the last time we
saw a Star Wars movie was 2019 and I get
it they wanted to slow down and just
kind of like reshape the brand but I'm
just excited that we can all now go into
a movie theater and watch Star Wars
together again I feel like we've all
missed that in our life so I want to
hear from you in the comments below what
do you think the odds are that we will
see Taylor Swift show up in the trailer
for Deadpool 3 on Super Bowl Sunday do
you think we'll see her in the TV promo
do you think they'll save her for the
online version of it do you think they
will hold back do you think this is all
nothing and she's not going to be in the
movie at all I feel like if she is going
to be in the movie they're going to put
her in that Super Bowl promo they're not
going they're not going to treat that as
a spoiler that they're going to wait
till people go to the movie theaters to
watch they're going to use the fact that
she's in the movie to sell as many
tickets as possible and they know from
putting Harry Styles and post credit
scene of ET internals that you can't
keep that stuff secret anymore anyway
comment down below does this make you U
you know someone who's going to want to
buy shares of Disney I guess thanks for
watching new Rockstar again tickets are
still available for our live show on
February 15th it's going to be a lot of
fun the best way to support new rock
stars is to grab one of these Multiverse
tour obviously we're we got a couple
swifties working at new rockstars so
we're jumping on the bandwagon 2 I'm
Eric Boss thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
bye
he